here with us former deputy assistant to
the president Fox News national security
strategist dr. Sebastian Gorka the
author of the bestseller the Geraldo
show Fox News correspondent at-large
Geraldo Rivera or although think of the
issues this is the Democratic Party they
want to raise taxes they've said so they
are saying to each other don't don't
tell anybody but we want to impeach the
president we want to do it but just
don't say it please please back so you
water stop then of course they want open
borders you heard what Nancy Pelosi said
about ms-13 and they want to keep
Obamacare now well you think those are
gonna be big issues in November I think
that the immigration issue is the
hot-button issue come November show and
I think that that will be the one that
really resonates and separates the
parties I have a cautionary note because
I am a Republican and I don't want a
Democratic majority because I think they
will endeavor to impeach this president
our friend who's doing I think a
terrific job but he is my cautionary
note when you use words like animal you
have to be very careful that you're
specifically referring to the people who
are animals who are savages these gang
members and not paint the immigrant
community with a broad brush we have the
absolute right to protect our borders we
have the absolute right through hard
police work through walls you know
through an any kind of effort that is
legal but we do not have the moral right
to separate migrating children from
their parents I don't want us to lose
this issue by doing something that is so
okay but you believe let's build a wall
let's have a wall with the door you're
okay with that
I'm okay with that as I said I would
like to see the wall it on the one side
and the dreamers given a pass a green
aggressively offered that Democrats
didn't take that deal right
the Democrats want that deal dr. Guha is
this ad am i right on the four big
issues of 2018 oh I think it's
absolutely clear I think nothing's
really changed except that presidents
delivered on those key issues he started
to build the wall the figures from DHS
for customs and
to patrol a stunning and it really will
be the economy and national security yet
again and the bottom line is Sean the
Dems don't have a message they're
whispering in the background about
impeachment but who's their real leader
where's the catalyst managers open
borders higher taxes and impeach the
president obama care more jobs for ms-13
that's their message i mean it's it's a
message that's insanity
it literally is trump derangement
syndrome when Nancy Pelosi gives out a
written statement last Friday saying the
National jobs figures mean little what
you will not see this is the first hours
the first time ever that we have full
employment when you've got more jobs
available than people looking for jobs
Nancy what do you want you want more
unemployment take the crumbs back the
two thousand dollars in crumbs the
average Maya no thank you
right there although you know when
you've built for the first time in our
history her although we have more people
more jobs than people unemployed
historic low unemployment fourteen
states for Hispanic Americans African
Americans and women doctor Gorka hits a
good point here Sean the problem with
this divided society is that we're not
being really on the same team we cheer
against our president success no we Emma
Krantz to know Democrats are cheering
for America to fail right now they can't
stand his success because it hurts their
put their their opportunity to gain
power that's a fact
well I tell you when it comes to the
poor for example the North Korean
negotiations I want everybody to be on
the same team cheering for success for
the president that's a stupid image that
President Trump face that's not they are
look the Democrats don't want America to
succeed that's the bottom line and
that's why they want to sabotage the
president and it's it's absolutely
mind-boggling horrible position to be in
thank you both